i remember when i was around your guy's
age man i i had a lot of weird jobs but
i will tell you my favorite weird job i
ever did
and it wasn't a weird job it was just
weird that they hired me to do it
i i entertained at children's parties
so and by the way at the time my only
means of transportation was a moped
and um well this was so bad guys and the
moped the muffler was broken so it
sounded like a harley it sounded like it
like okay
and i didn't have enough money to fix it
so you would think that carly was
driving down the street and you turn
around it was me on a moped like flink
so this dude who owned the the company
you know for the parties he you had to
go dressed in character you know and he
assigned your character everybody else
got like
captain america
iron man he gave me clown
he wouldn't let you show up dressed like
this you had to show up in costumes so
the kids
never saw you had a costume right which
was probably fine for everybody who had
a car
dude one time i was on my [ __ ] moped
like
dressed like peter pan at a stoplight
and this cop pulls up to me and he rolls
down the window he goes
he goes hey i said yes sir he goes i was
going to give you a ticket for no helmet
but
looks like your life's going bad enough
as it is
i was like yeah you're not wrong [ __ ]
off but you're not wrong
[Music]
that's how big our titties were they
made that noise through the air